LSD Psilocybin Meskalin und Ayahuasca
alles gefährliche Drogen oder das ist
zumindest die Idee die man bekommt weil
die Stoffe alle international verboten
oder zumindest stark reguliert sind aber
das Verbot schränkte nicht nur den
Missbrauch dieser Substanzen ein sondern
auch ihre Erforschung als medizinische
Wirkstoffe und hier gibt es richtig
viele unglaubliche Erfolgsstories
psychedelica sollen gegen Depressionen
helfen Angststörungen heilen und auch
bei Cluster Kopfschmerzen
posttraumatischen Belastungsstörungen
und Substanzmissbrauch helfen könnten
diese Drogen also am Ende sogar Leben
retten wenn sie denn richtig eingesetzt
werden seit einiger Zeit wird wieder
richtig viel ein klassischen
psychedeliker geforscht es gibt einen
regelrechten Boom an spannenden neuen
Studien wir haben Sie gelesen haben mit
ExpertInnen aus dem Gebiet gesprochen
und beantworten euch heute alle Fragen
zum Thema
fast jeder Mensch erlebt irgendwann mal
eine depressive Phase man ist
demotiviert und traurig müde und
konzentriert und lustlos das
Robert-Koch-Institut hat ermittelt dass
in den Jahren 2019 und 2020 rund 7 bis
10% der zufällig am Telefon Befragten
Erwachsenen in den zwei Wochen vor der
Befragung depressive Symptome hatten je
nach Schwere der Erkrankung fällt die
Behandlung unterschiedlich aus viele
Menschen empfinden Depressionen als
Stigma da kann eine professionelle
Aufklärung helfen man animiert sie auch
sich in der Natur zu bewegen und unter
Menschen zu geben wenn das nicht genügt
wird zusätzlich oft eine Psychotherapie
verschrieben und bei schweren Fällen
kann diese Therapie dann noch mit
Medikamenten unterstützt werden nämlich
Anti depressiver
Antidepressiva helfen vielen aber leider
nicht allen bei bis zu 30% der Menschen
mit Depressionen schlagen all diese
Therapien nicht an wir brauchen also
bessere Medikamente und da hoffen einige
Forscherinnen und Forscher ich hoffe mit
einem vielleicht etwas fragwürdigen Ruf
klassische psychedelica
die klassischen Psychedelika sind LSD
Psilocybin Meskalin und DMT sie werden
aus Pflanzen und Pilzen hergestellt oder
extrahiert lSD ist die Abwandlung eines
Stoffes aus dem purpur-braunen
Mutterkornpilz der wächst auf Weizen und
ist super giftig die anderen klassischen
Psychedelika stammen aus Pilzen und
Pflanzen die seit Jahrtausenden in
schamanistischen Ritualen Verwendung
finden DMT ist der Wirkstoff in einer
vasca einem Tee aus verschiedenen
Pflanzen und was passiert wenn man den
trinkt das könnt ihr euch bei tomato x
ansehen
aber wie genau wirken diese Substanzen
die klassischen psychedelica sind
Antagonisten also Gegenspieler eines
bestimmten Serotonin Rezeptors das heißt
sie verhindern dass Serotonin an diesen
Stellen wirken kann das führt vermutlich
dazu dass die Hirnrinde weniger Feedback
an die Regionen zurückgeben kann die zum
Beispiel Sinneseindrücke verarbeiten was
dann passiert wird oft als eine äußerst
intensive Erfahrung beschrieben ein Trip
man verspürt in der Regel einen leichten
Schwindel Rastlosigkeit und
Halluzinationen z.B sieht man
kaleidoskopische Farben und Formen ob
ein Trip als Traum oder Albtraum erlebt
wird hängt von den inneren und äußeren
Umständen ab Forscher sprechen hier von
Set und Setting Set steht für das
mindset es geht also um die Absichten
und Erwartungen mit denen zum Beispiel
eine Probanden Psychologie nimmt aber
auch um das seelische Befinden in dem
Moment das Setting sind die weiteren
Bedingungen also die anwesenden Menschen
und zum Beispiel die Gestaltung des
Raums für die evidenzbasierte Medizin
wurden psychedelica interessant nachdem
albert Hofmann in den 40er und 50er
Jahren LSD und Psilocybin aus Pilzen
hergestellt bzw extrahiert und an sich
selbst getestet hat wegen ihrer
aufheiternden Wirkung wurden
psychedelica daraufhin als Mittel gegen
Depressionen vorgeschlagen und
entsprechende Forschung betrieben aber
nach dem internationalen Verbot der
psychedelica Anfang der 70er wurde das
extrem schwierig nur wenige Projekte
wurden bewilligt teilweise wurde sogar
im Untergrund geforscht erst seit dem
frühen 2000ern ist die offizielle
Forschung wiederbelebt und zurzeit boomt
das Interesse geradezu vor allem in den
USA aber auch hier in Europa dabei
müssen die alten Erkenntnisse erst noch
einmal überprüft werden denn die
Methoden aus den frühen Jahren der
psychedelica Forschung sind inzwischen
etwas überholt es werden deshalb viele
klinische Studien durchgeführt und die
Anwendung der unterschiedlichen psyched
Kommentar zu testen bei der Behandlung
von Depressionen mit Psychedelika wird
natürlich darauf geachtet dass Set und
Setting stimmen das bedeutet die
probandenen und Probanden werden erst
einmal über den Versuch und das jeweils
verwendete psychedelicum informiert und
so auf die Behandlung vorbereitet am Tag
der Behandlung wird darauf geachtet dass
die Versuchsperson in einem seelisch
guten Zustand ist also zum Beispiel
keine akuten Angstzustände hat der
Proband oder die Probanden wird während
des Trips von medizinischen Personal
begleitet das natürlich auch die Dosis
vorbereitet hat meistens wird das Licht
gedimmt manchmal auch leise Musik
gespielt je nach Studie wurden ein oder
zwei solcher Sessions gemacht nach der
Behandlung werden die probandenen und
Probanden dann unterschiedlich lang
weiter betreut und Ihr Wohlbefinden
abgefragt wir haben uns vor allem diese
Meta-Analyse hier im Detail angeschaut
und einige weitere Meter Analysen
gesichtet sie fassen die Ergebnisse von
Einzelstudien zusammen um einen
Gesamtbild der Forschung wiederzugeben
die Frage war helfen Psychedelika gegen
Depressionen und wenn ja wie gut
insgesamt erscheint uns die Datenbasis
da tatsächlich noch nicht sehr gut zum
Beispiel wurden hier aus über 100
Studien zum Thema nur neun in die
Analyse aufgenommen davon wurde 6 mal
Psilocybin getestet zweimal Ayahuasca
und einmal LSD das heißt die Ergebnisse
für psilocybinen dominieren die
Datenlage in dieser Analyse auch die
anderen Meter Analysen haben am Ende nur
wenige Studien betrachtet aber nicht
immer dieselben und auch die jeweiligen
Autorinnen und Autoren finden dass man
einfach noch mehr wissenschaftliche
Forschung braucht ein Problem für
klinische Studien am psychedelica ist
vor allem die sogenannte Verblendung der
Goldstandard in der medizinischen
Forschung sind ja randomisierte doppelt
verblendete Kontrollstudien also wir
haben zwei repräsentative Gruppen eine
erhält das Medikament die andere ein
Platz wo und weder die probandeninnen
und Probanden noch die Forschenden
sollen wissen wer in welcher Gruppe ist
bis die Daten erhoben und ausgewertet
sind das ist die besagte Verblendung
aber Überraschung jeder Mensch merkt
halt sofort ob er auf einem
psychedelischen Trip ist oder nicht ein
zweites Problem ist der sogenannte
publikationsbasis es werden eher klar
positive Ergebnisse veröffentlicht als
negative oder unklare Ergebnisse aber
all diese Probleme mit der Forschung
haben die Autorinnen und Autoren der
mieteranalysen so gut wie möglich
berücksichtigt insgesamt kommen Sie und
andere forschende zum Schluss das
Trommelwirbel bitte Therapien mit
klassischen Psychedelika sicher und
wirksam sind
besonders fällt auf wie schnell sie
wirken Antidepressiva wirken meist erst
nach einigen Wochen der Einnahme aber
eine Psychedelika Behandlung beendet
eine depressive Phase sofort das ist
übrigens auch bei Ketamin der Fall
Ketamin gehört nicht zu den klassischen
Psychedelika weil es eine andere Wirkung
hat aber es wird seit kurzem auf ganz
ähnliche Weise für die Behandlung
schwerster Depressionen eingesetzt nach
einer Behandlung wirkt Ketamin bis zu 3
Wochen nach aber die Therapien mit
klassischen psychedelica vermindern die
Schwere der Symptome teilweise mehrere
Monate lang bevor wir zu den
Nebenwirkungen kommen und glaubt mir ihr
werdet positiv überrascht sein möchte
ich euch über ein anderes Thema mit
massiven Nebenwirkungen aufklären der
durchschnittliche dr Watson Zuschauer
ist gleichzeitig auch ein Herr wie
Internet User und mit jeder
Online-Anmeldung jeder Registrierung und
jedem Einkauf gebt ihr großzügig eure
Daten weiter leider geht nicht jede
Plattform sinnvoll mit euren Daten um
das betrifft im besten Fall nur eure
Namen häufig auch eure e-mail-ad aber in
ganz extremen Fällen sogar eure Fotos
oder Bankdaten deshalb will ich euch auf
inkognit aufmerksam machen das ist ein
unscheinbares Tool das ich persönlich
empfehlen kann weil es genau das tut was
eigentlich jeder machen sollte es löscht
eure privaten Daten wo sie nicht
hingehören dafür müsst ihr nur eure
Betroffenen E-Mail-Adressen angeben und
schon legt im Cockney los das Tool fängt
an nach euren Daten im Netz zu suchen
und schaut in erster Linie auf
Plattformen nach die Datensätze zum
Verkauf anbieten in einem zweiten
Schritt kann income dann Daten löschen
Anträge für euch stellen bei mir wurden
beim ersten Mal direkt 60 Löschanträge
gestellt aus eigener Erfahrung lege ich
euch daher ans Herz euren Datenschutz
ernst zu nehmen schaut unbedingt mal bei
inkogny vorbei und wenn ihr es selbst
mal ausprobieren wollt dann lasst euch
nicht unseren Rabatt entgehen mit
unserem Code dr Watson bekommt ihr
nämlich 60% Rabatt auf ein Jahresabo und
falls ihr dann doch nicht zufrieden seid
habt ihr natürlich 30 Tage Geld zurück
Garantie
okay wow klassische psychedelica wirken
also anscheinend schneller als
antidepressiver und sogar länger als
Ketamin aber was ist mit Nebenwirkungen
sind psychedelica nicht gefährliche
Drogen
zunächst einmal sind klassische
psychedelica viel sicherer als Ketamin
und andere Substanzen man kennt zum
Beispiel keine tödliche Dosis für LSD
oder Psilocybin man weiß nur dass sie
tausendmal höher sein muss als die Dosis
die einen Trip auslöst auch die Gefahr
abhängig zu werden ist bei den
klassischen psychedelikaten sehr gering
weil man bei wiederholten gebraucht
gegen die euphorisierenden und
psychedelischen Wirkungen resistent wird
und das kann man mit höheren Dosen auch
nicht ausgleichen LSD und psilo Zubin
sind in der Hinsicht deshalb sogar
ungefährlicher als Coffein
kurzzeitige negative Effekte also
umgangssprachlich einen schlechter Tritt
kommen im klinischen Setting selten vor
langanhaltenden negative Nachwirkungen
wie das triggern von Psychosen überhaupt
nicht das wird vor allem auf die
optimalen Bedingungen bei der Behandlung
zurückgeführt außerdem wurden Menschen
die schon einmal psychotische Episoden
erlebt haben von den klinischen Studien
ausgeschlossen aber auch in den Studien
die nicht in diese Miete Analysen
eingegangen sind sind Berichte von
Psychosen wenig mehr als anekdotisch was
tatsächlich bei relativ vielen Menschen
zu passieren scheint sind Flashbacks das
ist das gelegentliche Wiederauftreten
von leichten Halluzinationen für ein
paar Sekunden bis Minuten aber das
vergeht wieder wurde eher als angenehm
empfunden und hatte auch keine negativen
Auswirkungen auf den Alltag als
Partydrogen sind klassische psychedelica
aber immer noch riskant denn im privaten
Rahmen sind z und Setting unkontrolliert
und im Rausch kann man sich und auch
andere gefährden und schließlich weiß
man bei Pillen oder Drogen die man sich
irgendwie illegal besorgt hat nie so
ganz genau was da alles wirklich drin
ist aber als Medikament im klinischen
Kontext scheinen klassische
psychedeliker extrem sicher zu sein und
gegen hartnäckige Depressionen gut zu
wirken krass aber wie machen sie das
genau die aktuelle Hypothese ist dass
die klassischen psychedelica und auch
Ketamin das Gehirn für ein paar Tage bis
Wochen in einen Zustand höherer
Neuroplastizität versetzen
Neuroplastizität ist die Fähigkeit von
Neuronen zu wachsen und Verbindungen
miteinander zu knüpfen zu kappen zu
verstärken oder zu schwächen das Gehirn
ist dadurch Lern- und anpassungsfähiger
und damit auch empfänglicher für zum
Beispiel eine Psychotherapie diese
Hypothese wird dadurch gestützt dass
psychedelica im Tierversuch einige
Marker von Neuroplastizität verstärken
solche Versuche kann man bei Menschen
aber nicht so einfach machen deshalb ist
die Evidenz da auch noch nicht so ganz
klar die Forschung soll übrigens auch
klären ob die psychedelische Erfahrung
wirklich notwendig für den Effekt ist es
wäre ja denkbar dass man die
Neuroplastizität auch ohne die
psychedelische Erfahrung erhöhen kann
dann könnte man vielleicht wirksame
Medikamente entwickeln die die
Psychotherapie unterstützen ohne
gleichzeitig als Partydroge zu fungieren
auch für Menschen mit Angststörungen und
posttraumatischer Belastungsstörung wäre
das von Vorteil weil sie ein höheres
Risiko haben bei einem psychedelischen
Trip negative Erfahrungen zu machen
ich würde davon ausgehen dass klassische
psychedelica in Zukunft die Therapien
für Depressionen ergänzen werden es gibt
inzwischen schon einzelne
Forschungsgruppen und auch erste Praxen
die Sondergenehmigungen bekommen haben
um mit klassischen Psychedelika arbeiten
zu dürfen ansonsten bleiben diese
Substanzen in Deutschland aber erst
einmal verboten im klinischen
Zusammenhang haben sich vor allem LSD
und Psilocybin als sehr sicher bewiesen
außerdem scheinen sie eine erstaunliche
Wirksamkeit bei der Behandlung von
Depressionen und Angststörungen zu haben
und auch bei Clusterkopfschmerzen
posttraumatischer Belastungsstörung und
Substanzmissbrauch gibt es wohl
vielversprechende Ergebnisse das alle
Substanzen dieser Gruppe gleich für so
viele Einsatzgebiete die perfekte Lösung
sein sollen das klingt aber dann doch
etwas zu gut um wahr zu sein das finden
auch viele der Forscherinnen und
Forscher und genau deshalb braucht es
eben mehr gute klinische Studien
und auch die Grundlagenforschung zur
Neuroplastizität Hypothese dürfte sich
lohnen denn sie könnte zu Entwicklung
ganz neuer effektiver Medikamente führen
die vielleicht nicht die Erkrankungen
direkt heilen aber zumindest die
Psychotherapie effektiver machen können
alles mega spannend wir halten euch hier
natürlich auf dem laufenden abonniert
gerne den Kanal um das nicht zu
verpassen und bis dahin bleibt neugierig
euer Cedric